hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my video for the 10 things you might
have missed in season 3 part 9 of Twin
Peaks if you haven't watched part 9 yet
then this is your spoiler warning you're
gonna want to stop watching now please
check my Twin Peaks playlist for some
videos about the other episodes all
right so the first thing you might have
missed was Johnny who we saw running
through the house and smashing his head
against the wall was actually Johnny
horn and the woman that I mentioned was
credited as sylvia horn so Johnny horn
is the brother and I talked about him
when we were talking about Richard the
actor who played him wasn't supposed to
be coming back so he kind of thought he
was off the table but they did replace
him with a new actor so this is him and
he this could mean that he's tied to
richard horn you know the more exciting
theory about richard horn is that evil
coupe knocked up audrey while she was in
a coma but I really don't see where
Johnny fits into the picture
otherwise which doesn't mean that it's
for sure but it does mean that he's a
definite contender for being the father
and the one thing that kind of stands
out to me is that when we met Richard we
sort of had a scene where he came out as
a mystery like who's this guy and then
we found out who he was in the credits
and Johnny is kind of the same way the
next thing that you might have missed
was the search for the zone is an actual
website
I did notice this I mean it was on
reddit right away
I did notice this before I made my other
video but I didn't mention anything
about it because I hadn't had a chance
to get through it it's actually a
full-blown website and I would recommend
that you check it out if you haven't
seen it yet because there's a lot of
interesting stuff that I'm not going to
do anything I'm not going to go into it
too deeply here because you can make a
whole video about it but it is real it
does exist it's set up as a blog for
Bill Hastings and it has a really
awesome set up like it was made in 1997
which there is quite a bit of indication
that is
when he started making it so yeah it's
cool check it out for sure the next
thing is related to that and there were
coordinates at the bottom of this
website and we knew that he had found
some coordinates and then he had went to
where they had met the major and entered
the zone so these coordinates were
pretty exciting because they are real
coordinates and someone tweeted to mark
Frost about it what would we find if we
go there and Mark Frost replied you tell
me so it was obvious that it was safe
with nothing else unfortunately some
people from reddit got together and went
out and there was nothing of note there
as far as I know but I'll let you know
if anything ever comes out of that but
it is a real place it's in South Dakota
and people have inspected the
coordinates the next big thing that you
might not have noticed was that when
Diane receives the text that we saw able
to put into the small pink flip phone
the text ended up in all caps and it had
some punctuation whereas when evil two
had sent it from the flip phone it was
all lowercase with no punctuation so
this could be that I mean it's
definitely I think it's definitely not a
continuity error it could be but there
was another thing I read that someone
had posted that it says on the bottom
iMessage as if it came from another
Apple device this isn't something I'm
familiar with so forgive me if I'm wrong
here but apparently if it comes from an
Android it would say something different
like text message so there is a chance
that this has been relayed by another
person the first name that comes to mind
regardless of anything else is Philipp
Jeffrey's but it's kind of even more so
here because we know that the last time
evil coupe did something with the phone
that it was relayed to that box in
Argentina which is a big nod towards
Philip Jeffery so Diane is either
getting text from evil coupe and the
show was sloppy about how they portrayed
it or she's been in touch with Philip
Geoffrey's most likely since before he
went off the radar and during that time
when
no one else knew where he was either one
of those things is pretty exciting so
I'm definitely paying attention to this
the next thing you might not have
noticed this could actually be a debunk
or not I mean you guys tell me what you
think everyone myself included sort of
looked at this thing that bill Hastings
put on major Briggs his photo when he
signed it it looks like it says 9:20 now
that really wouldn't matter except for
that we know whenever Frank Truman
opened the cylinder from the same guy
with major Briggs he saw the number the
dates 10 1 and 10 2 and said that was 2
days from today and so on so if it was
9:20 that would mean that these
timelines aren't lined up and if you try
to think about it it becomes a major
major headache like it really doesn't
make sense because there's other events
that we know and yeah everything's sort
of nonlinear but it it's confusing and
it's really hard to kind of make it 9:20
so if you look at it really closely it
looks like that it might just be a weird
9 like there's a there's a little little
leg there so it could be a 9 that would
be the right date and that I feel like
that's the most likely thing now like
originally I thought it was a 0 but like
I said let me know what you guys think
the next thing might not be a thing at
all Bushnell whenever he's talking to
the 3 Fusco's which is the thing in all
of itself
if it's not Bushnell is not one of the
things you missed and the fact that all
three of the detectives are named Fusco
might be interesting to you but yeah
Bush now whenever he's talking to them
he does he see he's a boxer right so he
makes the fist I didn't think anything
that big of it at the time but a lot of
people are saying that he was doing some
of that code that we saw little do with
Gordon and Chet Desmond and fire walk
with me in other words hand in your
pocket means this making a fist means
that the police are going to be or the
local authorities are going to be
problem so yeah he does those things he
has a he has a sour look on his face he
has his hand in his pocket and he may
first three times but why he would be
making that code other than just a
callback to that scene is beyond me so
if you have a good explanation of why
that would be let me know because I
don't think he's telling the audience a
message there I mean we can tell by
looking at the detectives that they're
probably going to be asses and whatever
so yeah I don't really know but a lot of
people had brought that up so I'll put
it out there for you to think about the
seventh thing you might have missed is
that when evil Cooper talks to hutch and
Chantelle he stresses that he needs the
warden killed in the next two days so
later in the same episode we see that
those guys in Twin Peaks the sheriff and
the two deputies are headed to jack
rabbits palace at that same time to me
that seems like he wants warden Murphy
taken care of before this event that's
going to happen on 10 1 so there may be
more to warden Murphy than we originally
thought and that might be something that
has to do with the fact that he did let
evil coop go and had to get this second
kind of plan to have ray take care of
them so yeah again let me know what you
think about that the next thing that you
might have missed was the music and you
know I've been talking about this since
I started doing these things you might
have missed videos and there were a few
examples of the music here that was
pretty interesting when miss Briggs
started to tell the story about what the
major told her before about them showing
up you start to hear some music their
ike scene has some music that i'm pretty
sure was from fire walk with me and of
course we heard america the beautiful'
which has nothing to do with the
original run of Twin Peaks whenever
dougie Cooper was looking at the flag
but yeah some more music creaked in from
the original stuff hopefully that means
we're inching closer which I mean I
think the story is inching closer to
something happening in sweet Twin Peaks
now that we have this message from
Briggs but we'll have to wait and see
the next thing was that number 1997 that
year I should say as I mentioned with
the search for the zone website it says
the first visitor there
our visited in 1997 and we also found
out from the Fusco's that dougie Cooper
has or dougie Jones in this case has no
records prior to 1997 so it's a little
bit interesting that that year came up
twice in this episode and I feel like
it's almost impossible for those two
things to be unrelated bill Hastings
decides to build a website to talk about
this stuff and Dougie Jones is
manufactured I don't know I don't really
know what it means but it's definitely
interesting that they both mentioned
this date and while I was talking about
that the calendar where it says the
first visitor arrived at June 1st 1997
apparently that they've been fooling
around with the coding on that and the
guest number is now descending rather
than going up and someone on reddit
posted all the math there that it looks
like that what's going to happen is it's
going to count down to zero at the time
whenever the final two episodes air it's
something going to happen then we don't
know I'm sure but there's no way to know
what it is yet according to people who
know about such things and the tenth and
final thing that you might have missed
was this little piece of paper actually
I'll talk about those pieces of paper I
did talk about it in the first recap and
review video how that symbol from the
ace of spades was there that evil coupe
was looking for but this one with the
names and we it you know because of the
fact that it Hawk pointed out to
Cooper's and a lot of people are like oh
wait there's more there's more names
yeah we've seen this piece of paper
before and you couldn't tell exactly how
many times it said though named Cooper
it was at least three but there's a
finger in the pictures that I've seen so
there could be many more there could be
up to five someone said five I don't
know where they're getting that
information from but the point I was
making was is that he cut that piece of
paper out right there and placed it with
two inside the cylinder so it does seem
like a message to me anyways that he
wanted them to know that there was two
Cooper's because he had just met with
Cooper and we know from the secret
history that he after that made the made
a message and cording to bill Hastings
has been higher
whatever so I don't in my personal
opinion I don't think that there's a
half of a Cooper there because that's
leading to Doug dougie or anything else
I think it's just he cut it off so there
were two Cooper's so that's a message to
those guys let me know what you think
though and let me know what would you
think about all the rest of the ten
things and anything else did you see all
these as you see other ones do you think
there's better ones let me know in the
comments please like the video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel sorry about the little break
I've been traveling and having to deal
with embassies for the last two days but
everything is cool now and I'm back
ready for this weekend thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon